hallo ihr lieben der dezember steht ganz
kurz vor der tür und klingelt bei uns an
und deswegen komme ich heute mit einer
richtig weihnachtlich noweck torte mit
äpfel mit spekulatius mit einer leckeren
creme und das ganze natürlich wild
schnell hergestellt wenn man die
wartezeit außer acht lässt und ich zeige
euch jetzt zuallererst mal die zutaten
wir benötigen äpfel apfelsaft albertine
vanille extrakt außerdem puderzucker
sahne fest und spekulatius gewürzt
außerdem mascarpone magerquark und sahne
und natürlich spekulation skizze so ihr
lieben wir bereiten jetzt nämlich
zuallererst die apfel schicht vor und
dafür müssen wir natürlich die äpfel
vorbereiten und ich werde jetzt erstmal
scheel und dann das kerngehäuse
entfernen bzw
die äpfel in kleine vierecke schneiden
oder kleine stückchen besser gesagt
[Musik]
so die äpfel sind vorbereitet jetzt hole
ich mir kurz eintopf und dann geht's
weiter so in meinem kopf gebe ich jetzt
den apfelsaft und außerdem noch die agah
teen magazine ist ein pflanzliches
mittel und das muss einfach zwei minuten
sprudelt aufgekocht werden wenn geht es
schon ab ca 35 grad
das heißt eine super alternative zur
gelatine
das rühre ich das einmal schön glatt
[Musik]
so da gebe ich jetzt auch die
apfelstücke mit dazu aber noch nicht
einschalten den herz machen wir gleich
erst
[Musik]
so und daran noch einen guten schuss
vanille extrakt und bei dem man immer
exakt braucht euch keine sorgen machen
das ist komplett ohne alkohol
so jetzt schalte ich den herd ein und
dann das ganze aufkochen und das muss
dann wirklich zwei minuten sprudelnd
kochen
so die zwei minuten sind um und das
ganze ist jetzt fertig lies es aber
gerne noch mal zehn minuten ausdampfen
damit ich das nicht ganz so heiß auf
meine frischhaltefolie gebe und dann
kommen wir auch schon zum nächsten thema
nämlich unsere backform und ich nehme
hier eine ganz normale kastenform sieht
am ende nämlich richtig richtig cool aus
und damit unsere frischhaltefolie besser
hält nehme ich hier gerne backt rest
spray sprühe alles voller mit dem boden
und die seiten dann gebe ich die folie
da rein
[Musik]
das bewirkt nämlich dass wir später
unsere torte richtig schön rausnehmen
können dass es ein kinderspiel ich sag's
euch
[Musik]
sonst könnt ihr das noch ein wenig glatt
streichen passiert aber eigentlich ganz
von alleine und jetzt gehen wir das in
den kühlschrank für 30 bis 45 minuten
bis es richtig schön festwirt wir nutzen
aber die zwischenzeit und bereiten schon
mal die creme vor für die creme habe ich
mir da verzichte ich mal auf die
küchenmaschine und benutzers
handrührgerät und jetzt gebe ich dafür
mascarpone meyer quark sahne und auch
die süßungsmittel einmal in die schüssel
und dann hören wir das erst mal glatt
[Musik]
so das ist alles drin und jetzt noch
unser spekulatius gewürz das macht alles
ein bisschen weihnachtlicher
winterlicher schmeckt super lecker und
dann natürlich auch noch vanille extrakt
auch eine ordentliche portion würde ich
sagen so und jetzt werde ich das ganze
mit dem hand rühren jähriger stufe
solange mixen bis ich das alles
miteinander verbindet
so die masse hat nicht gut verbunden
jetzt gehen wir unsere sache fester zu
schlagen was eine minute ca auf volker
stuke richtig schön cremig und so dass
es auch richtig gut fest geht
[Musik]
so unsere spekulatius krems fertig die
gebe ich jetzt bis zur
weiterverarbeitung in den kühlschrank
die zwischenzeit nutze ich jetzt um ihr
so ein bisschen aufzuräumen und wenn die
apfel schicht ausgekühlt ist dann machen
wir endlich weiter so ihr lieben jetzt
wird die torte schön zusammengestellt
die apfel schicht ist richtig schön fest
geworden und da geben wir jetzt
zuallererst eine schicht spekulations
kick zu obendrauf
ich habe mir die kekse auch so ein
bisschen zurecht geschnitten damit sie
ihnen genau in die form passen
und jetzt gehen wir die hälfte der creme
darüber und dann wieder eine schicht der
spekulatius kekse
[Musik]
und das ist auch echt eine torte da
werden euch eure gäste fragen sag mal
bist du verrückt warum bist du so lange
in der küche gewesen
dann ist extra für uns und in wahrheit
geht es hier super schnell es ist ja
wirklich auch nur die wartung die kühl
zeit und alles andere geht ratzfatz ii
[Musik]
und ganz oben drüber kommen jetzt noch
mal spekulatius denn ist wieder später
so ein upside down kuchen dass ich die
apfel schicht ist am ende oben sind
richtig richtig gut aussehen
[Musik]
die torte ist soweit fertig vorbereitet
ich habe hier noch ein bisschen frischer
gefunden wer das jetzt noch mal schön
ordentlich bedecken und dann müsst ihr
nur noch die kühe zeit verachten drei
stunden muss das ganze kühlen aus
folgendem grund die creme wird richtig
schön fest und die spekulation die
weichen ein dann könnte das auch richtig
gut durch schneiden entweder könnte das
am vortag zubereiten oder wie gesagt ihr
wartet einfach drei stunden und dann
zeige ich euch nachher natürlich noch
die restliche dekoration und den
anschnitt
nach der kühl zeit wird die torte nur
noch umgestürzt auf eine servierplatten
und nach wunsch mit gehobelten und
gerösteten mandeln dekoriert und dann
könnt ihr euch die endlich schmecken
lassen mir persönlich schmeckt es
einfach total gut weil die ganzen
komponenten dabei sind abfüll
spekulatius von wille extrakt ich liebe
das und ihr könnt das ganze gerne
nachmachen und euch dazu die zutaten und
neben der infobox ansehen ich freue mich
natürlich wie immer wenn ihr dem video
ein dörfchen nach oben gibt fleißig
kommentiert und mir eure fotos mit dem
hashtag ich dieses kitchen auf instagram
zu kommen das ansonsten abonniert doch
gerne meinen kanal dann verpasst ja auch
nichts mehr
und dann kommen demnächst weitere tolle
weihnachtliche winterliche rezepte also
bis zum nächsten mal auf die tsg zum
schießt
[Musik]